allo alors quoi oui
ça vous dérange si j'entre non c'est un
bel appartement vous vivez seul oui tout
à fait vous avez un petit ami sale con
fortier vous savez si séparés il ya
quelques temps
c'était quand la dernière fois que vous
l'avez vu hier soir dans quelles
circonstances de l'or massif il est venu
me demander de l'argent et châtiment est
le 12ème le morceau
il s'en est pris à vous physiquement
c'est étrange pourquoi c'est d'être en
vie parce que sur les enregistrements il
allait redevenir très agressif
physiquement mais vous l'avez enregistré
à qui est ce restaurant ici c'est mon
appartement c'est pas un restaurant qui
est you may b suite à petite fille véra
vous avez besoin d'un peu d'air j'ai
besoin d'un avocat
ça d'être
ils peuvent toujours venir de le prendre
quand ils veulent qui sonne la police
c'est juste que lorsque vous avez appelé
la police c'est que vous avez demandé à
ce qu'il vienne pour ensuite raccroché
et puis vous avez dit que c'était un
accident
[Musique]
pourquoi pas face à des choses graves
arrivent toutes les cinq minutes mais si
c'était pas le cas n'aurais tu pas
travail
la plupart des hommes sont pas dignes de
confiance merci pour votre coopération
pouces est loué